they thought some of the things that I
could do were cool but I was not doing
the one thing you're supposed to you're
supposed to do grades and supposed to go
to school and focus instead I was this
long-haired bearded kid so I was you
know I looked like a up I probably
talked like what I was swearing all the
time and I was hanging out with a bunch
of musician people no one knew what the
hell to do with these kids and we all
assumed we were all on drugs and stuff
like that we were weirdly enough the
most like chilled out we didn't drink we
didn't smoke we didn't do drugs we were
just all we wanted to do was huddle over
a computer or play D and D or record
music play music out for with our
friends stuff like that and people you
know there were a lot of people that
assumed that we were bad news now funny
enough my high school many of the
teachers saw through it they're like no
these are great kids